welcome to this video our penguin
penguin penguin three or four is my
score against the sky okay we think
about it from wound and what actually do
I play here okay let's go to the let's
go with the book repertoire once again
g3 it's a bit uncommon and not putting
my cam just playing as unambitious Lee
as possible okay to stir exchange on
your hive yeah question is do i do it
still want to trade or just keep the
bishop maybe I just want to keep the
bishop put it on them back on e seven or
something just not trade it off it's not
necessary anymore to trade it and I have
Bishop u6 coming attacking see form
that's very solid this position okay um
a 3 i'm not sure about that i'm sure
about it sir giving white not much
basically weakening the queenside a bit
by okay just got c-5m okay it's got c5
that is that's still okay for one
nothing nothing great for him but not
not worse
yeah just centralized mmm yeah I can
think about putting something on d5 but
it's not really getting me getting me
anywhere okay maybe I can do something
yeah on the Kings side yeah he just
wants to treat everything and maybe
trying to get away with the draw it's my
guess okay yeah we have many peace
trades that's probably probably equal
some way for me forward now not really
and now is playing an ambitious move
taking okay how do I get this back
actually maybe he I am taking on edge
for
yah night h6 on is there anything better
I have no direct tactic here like night
f2r something like that okay yeah I
don't really think that this pawn is a
huge problem here that have that had
given away it still seems very healthy
my position I'd f5d for possibly all
night f5 to h4 not clear what you should
do probably yeah trade more trade more
um if i take sorry if I treat it if I
take H for now takes takes Knight e for
might be might be a bit of a problem
with them I have bishops is seven though
okay it's not a big deal so let's just
take the power back I can go here and
defeat place night d6 I just don't take
it and then f6 night f7 the pawn on d6
is unsupported yeah okay that's not a
problem
so we are going to play this end game
okay I think this this this d6 porn is
just just not very strong maybe I'm
wrong okay aha Kim this is in fact an
idea mmm how do i play now I can also
just take it you take be 79 f five
push-ups e 696 if i take it and he plays
Bishop g5 I take it and I have d8
covered by the night okay okay and now I
think he I am is more precise not night
night at five maybe very bishop d5 was
possible again the night coming to d6
will also protect the b5 pawn
yeah okay yeah i can even take age 3 now
but the question is some what about
should be force this a problem
we are might be maybe maybe still here
cover be five at a key tool and prepare
the King coming to to e6 quickly okay
this place and get another pawn to d 1
probably ah hmm what should I go a
sickly even home not totally sure maybe
maybe this is good just am fixing those
pawns make sure they're not going away
and now hi morning what is the best way
technically speaking to win this mmm
this should be a shock over I don't mind
to give a porn back if he takes on d6
I'm going to win this Rather's rather
easily to take those pawns and get the
Bishop to e2 maybe not so easy to win
not so easy to win at least I don't see
it
yeah I don't really see how to activate
you
how do i activate night b7 and 85 they
can come to f5 I Bishop c4 36 is good
yeah okay this is a good plan
yeah that's good and she does not really
have a great move now I think and I have
night c 4 and a 5 coming jack now maybe
Knight b6 was strong I am but okay still
not easy to one white 45 guys got King
f5 ya 92 I'm not sure it was it was
trickier the bishop pair is always
always not so easy to play against did I
make a mistake somewhere here that made
it so difficult to win mmm or was it
simply not that easy yeah the poor not
be five it would be a pretty trivial
when I think with the Holland b6 but the
point is on beehive the polymer be 50
weakens my dark square so much and it
was at least not so easy with this
limited time around here I don't see a
clear when he winning plan for me maybe
I need to regroup somehow trying to get
try to get a five and I mean this is my
extra pound it should move somehow yeah
yeah and not stir here I think I'm back
on the right track this this this should
be really should be a win somehow i have
night c8b 6cm that that's even better
prepare this idea on night c 4 p-6 so i
went here you went here take 694 and I
have Knight b6 or a 5 the computer wants
to own I'd be to our night be too we're
not be 22 d 3 and then before yeah
that's a pretty trivial win okay it was
it was of course influenced by by the
time but then surprisingly difficult to
win this even with this clear extra porn
okay thanks for watching